MALTE UBL: Welcome everybody, to
our talk about How We Make
JavaScript Widgets Scream.
My name is Malte.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And my name
is John Hjelmstad.
We're going to be talking a
little bit about the Google+
widget stack, some of the
extensibility issues that we
faced during it, and how we have
implemented a number of
different optimizations for
it to make it much more
performant.
Malte will start.
MALTE UBL: So those are some
of our widgets that we're
going to talk about.
You're probably familiar
with them.
There's the +1 button and
the Share button.
And they're supposed to go
on developers' site.
And one of them actually is the
Google Developers site,
which you probably all know.
And it's just another site on
the internet, just like you
guys can put a +1 button
on it, like this one.
And so we just want to
contextualize it a bit.
We're software engineers.
You guys are all software
engineers.
And we find it important
that the thing is cool
and fast and awesome.
So we want to share with you
guys the things we did to make
it really, really nice,
just to kind of
contextualize this thing.
So earlier this year, we
announced that there's over 5
billion impressions
per day, which we
think is kind of awesome.
It's nice to work on
a system like that.
I didn't actually do the math,
really, but it's a couple
billion square centimeters
of real estate
on your sites, right?
And just imagine, it takes a
second, so that's maybe, like,
5 billion seconds of load time
to websites across the web.
Hopefully not, but it could be
like that, so it's kind of an
important thing.
And so I just wanted to
talk a little bit,
like how they work.
And obviously you guys probably
know this, but just
from the high level.
So you start out by putting
some markup on your site.
Like this <div
class="g-plusone">.
And then we go and [? find ?]
this and we create an iframe.
This iframe displays the actual
widget, and the reason
why we need it is because first
of all, users are locked
in and they can click it, and
they get annotations.
But we don't want the external
site to ever know what person
that is, because that would
be bad for their privacy.
The other thing is, we don't
want evil hackers to do
automated clicks on the widget,
so we do it inside our
iframe sandbox on a
different domain.
And hopefully, altogether,
we get some profit.
So there's one interesting
concept that is important for
many things in our
talks, and that's
Bootstrap JavaScript files.
And so it's this thing
that's under
apis.google.com/js/plusone.js.
And it's a tiny file.
It has a short cache timeout,
which allows us to roll out
changes really fast.
And then there's more JavaScript
coming later, and
this JavaScript might
be kind of big.
So that's on infinite
cache time.
This is on short cache time.
So that's what a Bootstrap
file is.
It has no relation to the
Twitter Bootstrap project,
which maybe you guys know.
It's how I made this slide, on
[? Fire ?] and Web Inspector.
Anyway.
But so much for that.
And now we're going to talk
about performance in general.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah, so a
couple words on performance
that are probably a little bit
obvious but also just give us
a little bit of a mental
framework for how we conceive
of widgets overall.
I mean, it's been said a
thousand times that at Google,
we're obsessed about speed.
And there's a reason
that's the case.
I mean, I think everybody is,
or to some degree, ought to.
Fast websites are much
more engaging.
They behave as you anticipate
and expect.
They're seen as more
professional.
You get a lot more click-through
and all the
other good metrics
that you want.
One thing that we need to
recognize is that if you add
anything to a page, whether it's
a small div, a little bit
of text, some JavaScript,
CSS, anything--
the page will gain weight.
And so the way that we need to
conceive of this, really, is
in terms of the social widget
value system, as it were.
And it's again, fairly
obvious--
MALTE UBL: Actually, we don't,
but it sounds good.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Fair enough.
But basically, I mean, for
anything that you do--
and again, fairly
straightforward-- you need to
make sure that whatever
awesomeness you're adding to
the page-- the engagement, the
click-through, the ability to
interact with friends,
whatever--
needs to be greater in value
than the additional amount of
time that it takes to make
that happen, which is, of
course, the overall topic
of conversation.
MALTE UBL: Yeah.
Whenever you talk about
performance, it's very, very
important that measurement
is like the core part.
So never do anything before you
know you're actually slow.
And so there's many ways to do
measurements, and one of the
most important one is the
objective measurements.
And actually, Google Analytics
provides very nice tools that
give you info about your
site's performance.
And you can do custom tracking,
where you say, I
want to know how fast, in the
real world, it is actually
from here to there.
So that gives you real numbers
in the real world, and you can
tell whether you're
fast or slow.
And this link--
I'm going to share the
slides later on--
points to the page on Google
Analytics that shows you how
to do this.
Then there's perceived
performance, which we're going
to talk about a lot today.
It's not as easy to measure,
but it's really important.
So how fast does it seem?
And you get that through
indirect metrics.
So if you make your site faster
and your conversion
rate goes up, that's an indirect
metric of how you
could see what the impact of
perceived performance is.
And obviously, you can do things
like ask users and ask
QA, hey, how does it feel?
And the last pillar, obviously,
is the raw metal
benchmarking, which should
be the last thing you do.
But at some point you want
to know, what am I
spending time on?
And you do that with
benchmarking tools and
profiling tools.
This is how we do this.
So the metrics are--
I just made them up.
But the actions and
the variable is
something we track.
So for the +1 button, there's
this thing called Widget
Display Time, which we find
really important.
It's the time from starting to
load until making it to pop up
on the page.
And so there's some median
milliseconds, how long it takes.
And that's interesting, so
we track this and see
how we do over time.
And sometimes, some engineer
has an idea.
Like, what could you do?
And that's when we
do experiments.
Really important.
Known as basically
A/B testing.
You can do more variants.
But what we do is, we have
this awesome idea.
We implement it, and then we
roll it out to a subset of
your users and see which of
the ones does better.
And it's not always--
sometimes intuition is wrong.
But these objective measures
will tell you which one is
better, and then that's
the one you launch
and that you take.
One thing that we use all the
time, now that we know we're
slow, is this Chrome
Timeline View.
Who knows about this?
So it's part of the
Chrome dev tools.
And I think it's not
used very much.
So you record how your page
loads, and then you have all
these things.
Sending a request, CSS
calculations, JavaScript
evaluation, all those
things are in kind
of a waterfall graph.
And that's where we go and see,
hmm, what is this doing?
Could maybe two things
happen in parallel?
And so this is the main
tool that you--
when your site is slow, you want
to use this to see what
you're spending time on.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: So what are the
themes that we are trying
to run through this entire talk
about some of the things
that we think about when trying
to optimize performance
and make sure that
we are correct in
implementing anything.
So Steve Satter--
this is somebody that many
people have heard about.
He works at Google and he's
been, for the past decade or
so, advocating a number of web
performance best practices.
Among them, and ones that we
particularly focus on, are, as
Malte said, measure everything
that you do.
Make sure that you can reduce as
HTTP requests as possible,
because they are expensive,
particularly on mobile, but in
pretty much every environment.
Maybe even worse when you
have DNS lookups and SSL
handshakes.
If you can, do everything
async, which of course,
actually, to some extent
balances off of performance,
in that you are by definition
yielding.
But it's great because you can
take advantage of async
capabilities in the browser,
of course, to load multiple
resources in parallel.
And as well, you're being
essentially nicer to your
containing context, particularly
in our sense, for
widgets, in that we yield to
whichever containing page's
code exists.
A corollary to that is,
do as much as you
possibly can in parallel.
It's a fairly basic tenet, but
if you can load multiple
resources, do so.
CSS, JavaScript--
to the extent that you can
maintain semantics.
And lastly, Malte talked a
little bit earlier about
perception.
That's a much more semantic
concept that we tried to weave
through our observation in our
analysis of the way that
widgets work, and it's
very context-specific
for any given product.
But the idea being--
typically, people, of course,
see an application first and
then later interact with
certain components.
And you can instrument to
various degrees of specificity
to find out what's
most likely.
Is the user more likely to
start searching first?
So you'd preload that code.
Hover over this particular
element?
Preload that code.
And then deal with some
balances there.
So just a couple more words
about some of these concepts.
Reducing HTTP cost is valuable
because it reduces DNS lookups
cached in the OS
and/or browser.
Likewise, SSL.
Some ways to do this, of course,
are to either just
combine JavaScript libraries
together, combined images
together using CSS spriting,
or even inline resources.
Now, there's some balances
there, and we'll be talking
about that a little bit later,
in that you might reduce
caching, but at the benefit of
having fewer cache lookups in
the browser and possibly
cache misses.
And as well, new-ish
technologies, although they
are becoming more widely
deployed, such as SPDY in
particular.
MHTML is relatively new, too.
These allow multiple resources
from the same domain, even if
they're not explicitly combined,
to share the same
requests underneath the pipe.
So maximizing parallelization--
and we just mentioned before.
Load scripts asynchronously.
Preload as much as can.
If you know you're going to be
loading an image at some point
and it doesn't cost you that
much, asynchronously load in
the background, you'll have
a cache it right there.
And in the case of widgets in
particular, I mentioned, we
always make sure that we play as
nicely as possible with the
containing page.
Don't leak symbols.
Make sure to have an async
embed snippet.
And load whatever resources
you possibly can
asynchronously, because
JavaScript, of course, is
single-threaded and you're going
to essentially block CPU
compilation and execution
of code while you do so.
Lastly, I said a couple words on
optimizing for perception,
so I don't need to go over
that too much again.
But really just to understand
your product.
Take a look into what needs to
happen first, what the user
will perceive as being
really fast.
And do that first.
And do whatever else
you can lazily.
MALTE UBL: So having talked
about the best practices that
are fundamental to all the
optimizations that we did,
there was this one thing that
kind of surprised us.
And going there, it's that
JavaScript compilation is
really slow.
And you see all those talks
about JavaScript performance
and it's going up like crazy,
but many applications actually
don't do that much JavaScript,
but they load lots of it.
And so what happens when you
load JavaScript is you have to
parse it, you have to compile
it, and then you execute it.
And especially in our case, but
doubt it's too uncommon,
is that this last
execution part
isn't really that important.
Where we spend lots of time
is this first part.
And just for the ballpark,
roughly one millisecond is
spent per kilobyte of JavaScript
compilation.
Might not seem a lot, but
imagine that you have a
megabyte of JavaScript, which
isn't all that uncommon
nowadays, especially because
this is the size after
gzipping, right?
So not the network size.
It's the actual size on disk.
And so that takes a
second to load.
And it's fully blocking.
In all currently released
browsers, when you compile
JavaScript, you do nothing
else in [INAUDIBLE].
And that's something that we're
going to spend lots of
time on, this talk.
John?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: So let's talk
about how the +1 button is
actually loaded and some of the
steps associated with it,
some of the requirements that we
had at the very beginning.
We'll be the first to admit that
we didn't start out as
quickly as we really
wanted to.
And the reason is that we
started out with a six-step
waterfall, each of which
corresponded to some
requirement that we had in
making the widget work, which
extended to all other widgets
after that, too.
So we diagrammed this here,
and you'll be seeing this
graph throughout the course
of the discussion.
So you start with,
as Malte said
earlier, a Bootstrap script.
It's responsible for driving
everything else.
We chose to make it as
simple as possible.
So there's as few semantics as
possible associated with that
particular snippet.
Fewer things to go wrong.
That, in turn, in order to be
nice, essentially, to our
containing context, loaded
some JavaScript
asynchronously, which was
responsible for our parsing
widget markup, converting it
into iframes, installing event
handlers for hovers and
confirms, various other
semantics, which
drew an iframe.
The iframe is what the
button actually is.
Internally, it loads the second
half, essentially, the
in-iframe component of the
cross-domain communication
libraries for hover and confirm
behavior, click
behavior, and the like, as
well as CSS imagery and,
obviously, the HTML that
comprises the button itself.
And then at the very end is
another interesting step that
is not totally intuitive.
We had the button signal
back to its parent to
say, hey, I'm ready.
All is well and good.
And the reason we do that is
that if anything goes wrong--
there's a network stack issue,
there's something wrong on our
side, there's a
misconfiguration, anything--
we don't want essentially for
every page that has +1 buttons
and others to look
really ugly.
We would prefer to show nothing
than to show a small
404, 500, or what have you.
So from here, we're going to
go on to describing how we
will take all these
requirements, maintain them,
optimize for perception, and
make sure that we minimize the
amount of time associated for
the most important things to
occur as possible.
MALTE UBL: Yeah, and the first
thing, which we called "ping,"
is focusing on this last bit
of the waterfall, and in
particular, the part that we
call "render via parent,"
which happens at the very end.
As John said, it's important
to avoid us
ever showing bad things.
So again, we loaded
the iframe.
Now we know there's
no problem.
It's all good.
We can show it.
Then we load, parse, and compile
lots of JavaScript.
And then we tell the parent
page to show us.
Now, it's not really entirely
unobvious that you could kind
of change this and say, why
don't we tell, when we loaded
the iframe, the parent page
right away if we now are kind
of ready to draw.
And then after that, do the
loading, parsing, and
compilation.
So basically giving the
browser the control
over when to render.
And that turns out to give
quite a bit of benefit in
loading, nicely visualized
on here.
So basically, all this last
part of your waterfall is
being shaved off the time that
we took for the earlier widget
display time.
Going back to the waterfall,
there's still the same steps,
but the last part kind of
switched around, and now the
final step, the rendering
via parent, is
one step up the waterfall.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And a quick
corollary to what Malte is
saying as well, earlier, Malte
describe the widget display
time metric that we track.
It's interesting to note that
when we do this exchange of
when we actually signal to
render via parent, what we're
really doing is optimizing for
when the widget shows up.
Now when it's able to receive
full interaction is
a slight bit later.
Now the slight bit later really
multiplies, in terms of
the snappiness and the feel of
the button on the page, and
it's extremely rare for
people within the--
[INAUDIBLE] within that
additional savings in metric
to actually conceive of what the
page is, say I want to +1
it, annotate it or whatever, get
down there, mouse over it,
and click it.
It makes no perceptible
difference, and so the
trade-off is very much
worth it to us.
So from there, we took a look at
what it would take actually
to scale our platform.
So we've got this one snippet
and we made a conscious
product decision that when we
wanted to support the + Share
button, and actually before
that, the Google+ badge, we
noticed that we were
getting slower.
And the obvious reason for
that, when you give it a
little bit of thought, is that
the Bootstrap was dumb.
All it did was just say, well,
I need to load some code that
can support +1 and Google+
badge and + Share button.
So that payload just continued
to get larger and larger, and
of course, that ends up being
blocking in terms of its
parsing and compilation.
One millisecond, in the median,
we found for those
stages, per kilobyte.
And so we found that we were
getting slower and slower.
We really wanted to make sure
that we scale accordingly.
So we made the Bootstrap
a little bit smarter.
It's, again, a pretty
straightforward concept.
In the initial phase, is the JS
payload is responsible for
parsing the or <div
class ="g-plusone">
or equivalent markup.
We moved that onto
the bottled.
And we made a sporadic decision
as well to make all
markup look, template-wise,
exactly the same.
It's either a  or
.
So the code associated with
that is extremely stable,
which is an important benefit.
And B, it's extremely small
and compact to write.
And so at this point, the
bootloader simply just finds
whatever's on the page.
It says, I found a +1 button
only, or + Share button only.
I'm just going to load what's
necessary for that, thereby
making the JS payload necessary
to work with it that
much smaller.
MALTE UBL: Yeah. and this was
not our most exciting part of
the presentation, because
the waterfall still
looks kind of the same.
But now we go into the next
optimization, which kind of
fell out of the last one.
And we call that Bootstrap
rendering.
And now we focus on those
first three parts of the
waterfall--
the Bootstrap, the JS
payload, the iframe.
So going back to that picture,
we load the Bootstrap, load
the payload, load the
iframe, show it.
Now we added the logic to kind
of discover those tags that
signal which widgets are on
a page to the Bootstrap.
And then we had the
brilliant idea--
why don't we teach the Bootstrap
to actually inject
the iframes?
It wasn't that easy, because
weird URLS had to be
constructed, so we had to do
quite some work to make our
platform more uniform.
But this has a quite big
impact on the thing.
And I want to show this here.
Basically, we always had this
JS loading, but it's now no
longer on the critical path.
So the Bootstrap goes and loads
the widget iframe, and
as soon as that's there,
we can be shown.
And it's no longer strictly
bound to the JS
on the other page.
And especially, it doesn't wait
for that to load to load
the widget.
Really, really big win.
Looking here, the waterfall
starts to get smaller.
So there used to be those two
things, and now the JavaScript
payload is completely
eliminated from
the critical path.
And that's quite a big
difference from before.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Definitely.
And it's still worth noting,
going back to the theme I
actually mentioned with respect
to Ping, that what
we're doing again is making the
observation that seeing it
is done in order of magnitude,
and in fact, many orders of
magnitude, to no surprise in our
particular case-- and of
course, like I said before,
every product is semantic.
You need to know how it's
interacted with.
You see a button and have to
really cohere what it does
before you actually
interact with it.
So when we implemented this,
we made sure to add
instrumentation to know exactly
how long it takes
until the full suite of
interaction is possible.
Because we're still loading
that JavaScript payload
asynchronously to make sure that
when you hover over the
button, you get the possible
Share box or the confirmation
dialog, and all that
sort of stuff.
And so from here, we moved on
inside the iframe, and took
note, as yet another corollary,
that not all +1
buttons, Share buttons, or
Google+ badges actually get
any interaction.
But they still provide a
tremendous amount of value.
A button says eight
people +1'd it.
Perhaps there's an annotation
that shows you which of your
friends happened to do so.
That has value on its own.
But if you never interact with
it, why are you even doing the
cross-domain communication?
Why are you actually parsing and
compiling, in particular,
the JavaScript inside
the button?
So this is an interesting
technique that can be
generalized in situations in
which this is the case.
And we call it "lazy JS
evaluation." We wait until a
signal of intent comes from
the user in the form of a
mouseover, or a touchstart on
mobile devices, and the like,
that we actually need to
evaluate JavaScript.
So before, our chart
looks as described.
We're loading the widget.
Inside, it's got
a bunch of JS.
And that JS just immediately
is parsed and compiled.
This adds nontrivial cost to
the browser in that it's
blocking whatever else is going
on that particular time.
Afterwards we signal
to show the widget.
What we taught the
code to do is
represented by this snippet.
This is not our exact code,
but it really does get--
MALTE UBL: We don't use
jQuery, but this is
pseudo-jQuery.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yes.
But it does get at the nature of
what it is that we're doing
within the buttons.
So we're loading some JS inside
of it, represented here
by /some/file.
And basically we say, hey, load
this as a string via XHR,
and only once that string is
loaded do we, on window, bind
these various events in the
capture phase on the top-most
element, which is, of
course, window.
And we say, on mouseover,
touchstart, keydown--
and click, actually, just
to be complete--
only then should you
synchronously evaluate
JavaScript.
And it turns out that because we
are capturing these events
at the top-most element and
then they bubble down, and
we're evaluating the code
synchronously, we only
actually parse and compile,
via eval, and evaluate the
code at that time.
It turns out to be pretty
notable win, and this is
especially true in situations
in which you
have multiple widgets.
But we found, to our surprise,
it's true when you have only
one on the page, because you're
being nicer to the page
context, whatever it might
happen to be, and you're
scaling a lot better with
respect to your widget itself.
So here, we have the
description of
kind of what's happening.
It becomes much more conditional
and there's some
complexity added here.
Malte will talk about that
in a little bit.
Maybe you parse and compile the
JS, but if you don't, you
know you didn't need to.
There was never any interaction
in the first
place, which we found to be more
surprisingly beneficial
than you might even expect.
And like I said, it scales
extremely well.
You could have hundreds of +1
buttons on the page, and they
don't take up hundreds of
parse-and-compile cycles in
the browser, irrespective of
what JS engine happens to be
running them.
So afterwards, you don't even
have the parse and compile in
the majority case.
Again, that's specific to
widgets, but it could apply to
quite a few other applications
as well.
MALTE UBL: One thing to note
here is that previously, when
you had lots of +1 buttons on a
page, they could get really
slow and could use
lots of memory.
So this saves on that.
It's still kind of hard--
if you put a hundred iframes on
a single page, the browsers
still don't like that because
they allocate
quite a bit of memory.
But one example would be Google
Reader, where you
scroll down and it constantly,
as content
comes in, adds +1 buttons.
So these pages really gain
from this optimization,
because the frame rate doesn't
drop while JavaScript is being
compiled as the widgets
come into view.
Now, we move on to an
optimization which isn't as
important for the request flow,
but which is kind of
interesting and we still
wanted to mention it.
And it's for the case where you
have lots of widgets on a
page and they might get quite
a lot of interaction.
And in that case, they still
have all their own JavaScript
because they're independent.
And so we came up with a
technique that we call
code-sharing that kind of makes
lots of widgets on a
page be able to share
the same code.
So I mentioned this
page, which I made
using copy and paste.
So it has 112 iframes.
At some point, we actually
loaded two JavaScript files on
each iframe, so that's 224 JS
requests, which is kind of
suboptimal.
So we changed it to a
different technique.
But what this does--
the first widget loads,
parses, and compiles
JavaScript and it executes it.
The second widget comes in,
loads, parses, and compiles
JavaScript and executes it.
Kind of not cool.
So we came up with the 113th
iframe, kind of this shared
loader iframe.
So every time you would go a
widget, it loads this second
hidden iframe that's actually
responsible for providing the
JavaScript.
And so we have widget 1 and
widget 2, and they both take
their sources from
the same iframe.
Now, there's many ways
to implement this.
And it's actually quite a common
technique at Google.
We created a way that's actually
quite interesting
also for all you guys, because
it's generalizable to every
piece of JavaScript.
And I'm going to show
how it works.
So this is some random
JavaScript.
var d = "none" and then
document.getElementById,
querySelector and
style.display.
So don't worry about it.
Random JavaScript.
So who's a JavaScript expert?
All right.
I'm going do a transformation.
I'm going to add window.
in front of the perceived global
variable document.
So JavaScript in the
browser doesn't
actually have double variables.
At least, they're not
as important.
They're all actually properties
of window.
So you can go through a
JavaScript file and find all
the references to global
variables,
and then prefix window..
Does it make sense?
Kind of, right?
So window isn't actually
a magic variable.
You can wrap your script
in a function--
I call it javaScriptCallback--
and provide window as
a local variable.
So now, suddenly, your file has
become this thing that can
get a window injected.
So you can use the same
JavaScript that you only parse
and compile once and apply
it to different scopes.
And that's what's being
done down here.
So javaScriptCallback is being
called twice, once with the
iframe1 and once with
the iframe2.
So what this does-- it takes
any concealed bit of
JavaScript that you could come
up with and transforms it into
a form that can be applied
to as many window
contexts as you want.
So there's nothing that a
programmer has to do.
It works with all JavaScript.
Now, this is implemented in
Closure Compiler, which is an
open-source project release
for Google.
So there's no manual
transformation involved.
Nobody has to write window.
and can never forget it.
It's just being done
automatically to every single
global variable.
Notably except window itself.
Anyway.
So what this does, essentially,
is still, for the
first widget, it says, you
know, I kind of need this
file, and it's being loaded, and
you parse and compile it
and you execute it.
But the second widget, when it
wants the same JavaScript, all
this parsing and compilation
phase is not being needed
because you already have it.
And you just apply the same
JavaScript-- boom--
to the second window, which,
again, and similar to the lazy
JS optimization, considerably
minimizes the weight that you
get as widgets are being added
to the page, which, again, is
kind of a win.
Dorky.
Yeah.
And that was that.
Now we'll move on
to CSS inlining.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah, as a quick
aside, actually somewhat
related to the transformation
Malte's describing with
respect to circumscribing all
global references under
window, there's another
compiler pass--
just if you happen to be
interested in Closure Compiler--
that rescopes all implicit
global variables, like var(X)
= 1, to a namespace.
We use that to avoid polluting
the namespace space of the
containing page that
you're on.
It's called--
do you remember what?
MALTE UBL: Rescope
Global Symbols.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Right.
For anybody interested, look
for Rescope Global Symbols
under Closure Compiler.
It's an interesting technique
if you have the issue of
accidentally adding way
too many symbols
to the global namespace.
So from there, we are pivoting
to our last optimization that
we're going to be talking about
today, which again, is
within the iframe.
And this one is more of a pure
experiment, and we haven't
actually fully rolled it
out nor figured out the
particulars of when
it's most optimal.
But it's an interesting one
because it involves a number
of tradeoffs.
And I mentioned at the beginning
of the talk that
reducing the number of HTTP
round-trip or HTTPS
round-trips is incredibly
important.
In our case, we've got a
small amount of CSS.
It's about 2 kilobytes or so.
It references some sprites, but
it doesn't do a whole lot.
And we noticed a growing body
of suggestion literature on
the web and blog posts
suggesting, particularly if
you have a small CSS
file, it might be
beneficial to inline it.
So we're starting to experiment
with that, and we
actually have founder early
results that it, in fact, is.
Now, this is a classic tradeoff,
as mentioned before.
And so one of the big tradeoffs
is the fact that
you, if you get a low cache hit
rate, you're using more
network bandwidth and you're
getting essentially,
obviously, a lower hit rate by
definition in the browser.
In our particular case, we have
N billion impressions for
+1 buttons and the various
others per day.
And it seems like only 2
kilobytes of CSS, but it turns
out to translate to
2 Terabytes a day.
So it's particularly relevant to
us to figure out the right
variables here.
Now, the tradeoffs
are described
right here pretty easily.
And it's pretty classic, and
this applies to just about any
resource you'd like to inline.
But inlining itself, obviously
bad for caching.
If you have a great cache
hit rate, and our CSS is
infinitely cached.
You'd expect, somebody goes to
a page with a +1 button or +
Share, they go to another
one, boom.
It's already going
to be there.
Why would you cost
the additional
2kb on the next request?
Well, the reason is that you
guaranteed that there are
fewer HTTP requests in the cases
where you've got a poor
cache hit rate.
And we noticed, anecdotally,
that the hit rate is
particularly bad.
And we suspect that this
is particularly
suboptimal on mobile.
So it's something to
experiment with.
And the reasons for that
being the case on
mobile are fairly obvious.
Smaller devices, smaller caches,
various different
policies in effect on
different browsers.
But the good news about it is
that you end up, again, with a
definitional shorter
waterfall.
So who knows exactly
if it's a win?
But like I say, in the mean,
we have found it to be so,
particularly in pages where
there's only one +1
button on the page.
You know that you're at least
not sharing that same resource
across multiple on the page.
So it's an interesting one, and
I'd suggest people look
online, literally just CSS
inlining and various other
related searches to find
out the particulars.
But in our particular case, we
found that because we will
never be blocking on
that HTTP request--
very expensive on mobile as well
as more likely to occur
on mobile--
that it results in an overall
win in terms of performance
for our platform.
So in the end, we end up having
pretty much this waterfall.
We've got the Bootstrap.
It plops an iframe onto the
page and that iframe has a
tiny bit of inline CSS
that says, render me
because I know I'm safe.
The iframe itself
has CSS inlined.
It doesn't currently have the
image inline, but that's yet
another thing that you can do by
spriting and inlining that,
and we'll have to figure that
one out at some point.
And in about as short a time
as possible, given our
requirement to have a very
simple integration snippet,
you end up seeing the button.
And we're fairly happy
about that.
We've seen notable win.
And we, again, have
instrumentation that shows
that the amount of delay
introduced, in terms of the
tradeoff, in terms of
interaction, has not affected
any of our additional metrics.
So that's particularly
salient.
So just to review--
this is where we started.
We had six stages.
And it's interesting to kind
of walk through them one by
one, as we have, and point out
how some of them are really
not specifically required
upon further analysis.
So it really, really does
shorten things quite a lot.
MALTE UBL: So coming
full circle.
So we showed you, basically
opened our books, what we
spent our last, basically, year
on, how we optimized the
load speed of the +1 button in
particular, and all the other
widgets as kind of a second
effect of the same
optimization.
We just wanted to talk really
quickly about how you can
basically use kind of the same
techniques for your app or
application, whatever
you build.
Hopefully it's in HTML.
And we kind of assume you
already follow best practices,
because that's kind
of boring, right?
You all know this quote, Donald
Knuth-- "Premature
optimization is the root of all
evil." I mentioned this
before, but don't go in and
implement, like, lazy
JavaScript evaluation for your
site if your site has large
banners on it and that's why
it's slow, and not because you
have written your own little
jQuery application.
So yeah.
Kind of measure and see where
you're slow, which the next
slide is about as well.
I talked about how you can
use Google Analytics.
When you go back and have the
slides, there's the link where
you can check out how
you can do this.
It's not very much use,
but it's very cool.
It's something you have
to implement yourself.
So it gives you all these
metrics by default, but you
can use it to see how your
customers in production load
your site, by defining moments
on the page are
important for you.
So you get metrics on
how fast those are.
And then there is the Chrome
Timeline View that I talked
about earlier, which shows
you what your site is
spending time on.
And it's very interesting to
check out your site and see,
huh, maybe these two things
could happen parallel or it
could combine these resources.
Or maybe you see that you're
first loading a JavaScript
file, then a CSS file, and it
makes sense to switch them
around because then they're
in parallel--
stuff like that.
And what I wanted to point out
is that there is actually a
talk about real world web
performance optimization
measurement that's like actually
spending more time on
this than we are.
And it's tomorrow at the same
time as this one in Room 8.
And you should really
check it out.
Don't want to spend too much
time, but this is like--
if you remember anything,
right?
Reduce your HTTP requests.
It's what, unfortunately,
things spend time on.
Like, we try to fix it with
SPDY, but still, HTTP requests
have to go away.
You go to Chrome Network
View, see why am I
doing all this crap?
And can two of those
become one?
And can I maybe cache more?
This is something we did, for
example, for the CSS inlining
for the widget detection, to
just get fewer bytes on the
wire and fewer things happening
after another.
Parallelizing if possible.
Again, you go into Chrome
Timeline View.
You see, hmm, I downloaded an
image, and other image, and a
JavaScript file, and then they
kind of depend on each other,
and then the JavaScript
file loads an iframe.
Stuff like that.
It happens on every site.
So is there a way we can maybe
predict what you have to do
later and start it early
in a fashion-- and
that's usually async--
that it doesn't block?
Our Bootstrap rendering
approach did this.
The code-sharing thing as well--
as it parallelizes
JavaScript execution
across iframes.
And yeah.
We talked about this as well.
Optimize for perception.
I don't have to repeat it, but
really, really, really think
about your site.
What is the important part that
is super necessary for
the site to show so the user
thinks it's loading?
And try to write your site in a
way that this is the things
that can be loaded
independently, and then only
once that happens, maybe, do the
harder work that you would
like to avoid.
Obviously, our Ping stuff, the
lazy JS evaluation things--
they really make hard tradeoffs
of moving stuff to
the back by improving the time
it takes to really show the
first couple bytes.
And all of that together, we
hope we moved things forward a
little bit.
I hope you guys enjoy having
slightly faster +1
buttons on your site.
And that's it.
Thank you.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN HJELMSTAD: So
any questions?
AUDIENCE: I've got a couple
of questions.
One, the mantra that you
introduced at the beginning of
having a Bootstrap file that's
really small and doesn't cache
very long, and then having
your bigger file that you
change a lot be infinitely
cached?
It seems like by teaching the
Bootstrap how to draw iframes
and whatnot, all you really
did was use a different
technique there and decide that
it wasn't really useful
to have the two files.
Am I following that
incorrectly?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: No, that's
roughly it, actually.
I mean, we made the observation
that the parsing
phase, first of all, we designed
to be as simple as
humanly possible.
So it was wasteful for it to
be in the async payload to
begin with.
And that's a tradeoff we could
make, as well, right?
Like we don't really need to
capitalize on that higher
cache hit rate, to the extent
that we get it, actually.
Because I noted that CSS on a
cache rate was not even all
that great, and the
JS is larger.
And so it's a principle tradeoff
that you need to make
at that point.
It does, in fact, make our
bootloader a little larger.
Now in our particular case, it
was fortunate that we looked
into the bootloader and--
something we didn't mention,
but we looked at it very
carefully and closely and just
ripped out everything we
didn't strictly need, made it
way smaller, and then once
again inflated it to where
it was before.
So the needle didn't move
with respect to that.
And it's also worth noting, just
as a quick aside, that we
have experimented with but
haven't actually deployed some
techniques associated with
figuring out ways for the
bootloader's cache timeout to be
much, much longer, which of
course has its own tradeoffs,
because the bootloader needs
to be able to expire when you
have new code coming out, when
you have bug fixes, new
features, whatever.
But the technique which I just
think is interesting--
I'll say it very briefly, but I
don't want to deep-dive too
much-- is you extend
your cache time.
You add a tiny bit of code that
basically opens an iframe
that then opens another iframe
to your own JS file, which
then does a JS force reload.
High level.
But what it essentially allows
you to do is force evict,
using JavaScript, a cache
line from the browser.
So we may play around with
that one as well at some
point, but so far it hasn't
been critical path.
MALTE UBL: One thing to mention
is that the payload
does more than just
draw widget.
You mouseover and it shows
hovers, shows Share boxes.
So that's all stuff
that you don't
necessarily need to draw.
So there's, basically, some
stuff moved from the payload
to the Bootstrap, but it's the
stuff that's in the critical
path, as John said.
It didn't increase
the overall--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: That's
is very good point.
The parts that we moved in were
very much a minority.
The vast majority of it is the
complex positioning logic and
iframe communication logic and
authentication logic and so
on, having to do with the hovers
and interaction stuff.
AUDIENCE: So that's missing from
your waterfall because
it's not critical path, but
that part is still there?
MALTE UBL: Right.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: And the second part of
your waterfall, you moved--
at the beginning, you said that
you wanted to confirm
that everything loaded correctly
before you drew the
button so you don't end up with
an unstyled button or
something like that showing
up on the page.
AUDIENCE: And it seems that
moving your confirmation
before you've confirmed that
the CSS and JavaScript have
downloaded defeats the
point of doing that.
MALTE UBL: That's not-- so
it's not entirely true.
Basically, the highest
risk of not loading
is the widget itself.
So this happened recently to
another social network.
And you kind of want
to avoid this.
So when you're able to load
this widget, we're super
confident that we're able to
eventually download the CSS.
And if that actually doesn't
happen, then I mean, that's a
whole different point.
But it's something we're very
much not worried about.
So we know we are able
to deliver the widget
and we can show it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So it makes sense to always
asynchronously load the Bootstrap.
That makes perfect sense.
The question is, there's no
native method built into the
Bootstrap for when it's all
set up having the callback
injected into it from
the end user.
And while there are ways,
certainly, to kind of handle
on the front end-- there's weird
cross-browser stuff.
And I guess if you're trying to
promote best practices to
any web developer out there,
anyone who's, say, explicitly
rendering their tags or
anything, it feels like it
might be pretty simple to add
just that single callback, for
Load Ready or something.
MALTE UBL: So there's many
ways to do this.
The one I prefer is the way
Google Analytics handles the
same problem, where they use
this JavaScript array that you
push on to, which then later,
as the payload arrives, gets
upgraded to the actual thing
that does the work.
And this thing that you kind
of queued gets done.
But yeah.
So it's certainly something
that we could consider.
AUDIENCE: That'd be
awesome, yeah.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: I mean, the
onload support that we do have
right now, if you load
plusone.js--
MALTE UBL: Don't mention it!
It's ugly!
JOHN HJELMSTAD: It works
in two different ways.
The ugly way--
which I will acknowledge-- is
you just stick in an onload
parameter which is a function
name that is assumed to be in
the global namespace, sanitized
and whatnot, and it
will execute that.
Obviously that's worse for
caching across your own page
loads and those of others,
even within the 30-minute
current cache timeout
of the Bootstrap.
But there is a default onload
function, too, called
gapi_loaded, which will be
sought, and if it exists, it
will be executed once the
payload is executed.
So that actually is not
deleterious to a performance
in that way.
AUDIENCE: And it's called
gapi-dot-loaded?
Interesting.
JOHN HJELMSTAD:
Gapi-underscore-loaded.
AUDIENCE: Underscore-loaded.
And is that in the documentation
at all, for--?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: I hope so.
But it's probably
way down there.
We try to make our
documentation
as simple as possible.
AUDIENCE: I was looking
around just today.
I don't think it is in there.
So that would be helpful--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Very helpful.
I would agree with that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Cool, thanks.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
code manageability about it.
I mean, when you start to do too
many techniques, it starts
to make a unique custom solution
for the widget.
Is there any techniques or
things that you do if you're
having to change out HTML that
conflicts too much with the
inline CSS?
Any tips or tricks that you do
in order to make it more
manageable?
MALTE UBL: So first
of all, there's
definitely tradeoffs involved.
So I think lazy JS is the most
extreme one, because it's
essentially, you say, you cannot
do anything anymore
when you load.
And when your project manager
comes, you know, I have this
awesome idea.
I want to do this
when you load.
And then, oh, well, kinda
we can't anymore.
So it's a big tradeoff.
It also makes it much
more complex.
It makes it, like, from a script
tag to this, like,
process of getting source
code, much more complex.
And it's hard.
And this is why we
say measure.
Because there is complexity
in it.
There's no silver bullet
to solve this.
But if you know there would be
this possible optimization and
it's worth for you-- and the
model of whether something is
worth it for you might
be different.
When you're in an online
store, where it's super
important that people can shop,
maybe there's some pages
where you would never do this
optimization because they're
just not as important.
And for us, having all these
billions impressions per day,
there's often this thing where
this optimization which you
would never usually do becomes
kind of worth it, which is why
I kind of enjoy this job.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: It would be nice
if there was some like
cool engineering trick or
something that we had.
But when it comes down to it,
it's the much more boring sort
of suggestions, like,
make sure you
document it really well.
And in our particular case,
we're building multiple
different types of widgets.
Build them all on the same
templates, the same platform,
the same whatever, so at least
they all work the same way.
And then, you know, automated
tests and
all the boring stuff.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean, it'd be
real cool if you'd say, OK,
here's a preprocessor that
handles all this.
You write it one way and
redo all this for you.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah.
And that has to change how
it works internally.
MALTE UBL: I talked about
the code-sharing, right?
Most of this, like
the lazy stuff--
It's very transparent
to the JavaScript.
The JavaScript doesn't know it's
being optimized this way
with the code-sharing.
Again, because it's a
transformation in the
compiler, the JavaScript
doesn't have to be
written in the way.
So these are actually examples
where we kind of took the
framework and the infrastructure
[? layer ?] and
solved this problem.
So with the code-sharing, you
can tell the developer, you
cannot access window directly.
You cannot access document
directly.
You always have to go through
this indirection.
And if you do this
from the start,
it's also a cool decision.
But with this, it's basically
like, it's an infrastructure
thing that solves this problem
once and for all and makes it
usable for everybody.
And it's open source,
so it's like--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: The perhaps
amusing, perhaps just
straightforward expression we've
used for it is, we try
for everything to be as much
a semantic identity
transform as possible.
Lazy JS is not, which is why it
was one of the more complex
ones for us.
Inlining CSS--
on the back-end we've got a
template, and it says, load
this URL, in a link rel
or whatever tag.
And literally, there's just a
little if block that says spit
out that or do a back-end
request to the server that
would have spat that out,
and inline the result.
So to the extent that you
don't have weird caching
issues or whatever, and that
your URLs are stable and the
content is stable, it works
exactly the same
way, in that respect.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yep.
MALTE UBL: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Matt from Olark here.
So we have something similar,
where we have a chat box that
we embed on people's websites.
So one thing we're considering
for some new things that we're
doing is using localStorage
to do caching.
I'm just kind of curious if you
guys considered that, and
if maybe you ran into some
issues with it and that's why
you're kind of still sticking
with typical caching.
MALTE UBL: Yes.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: The
answer's yes.
We have experimented with
it and certainly
thought a lot about it.
MALTE UBL: Here's the thing.
For in-widget, for inside
the iframe, it's doable.
We don't want to do this on the
containing page because we
don't own it.
We would spam their
localStorage.
So within the context,
not a very good idea.
But yes.
Inside the iframe, we haven't
implemented it.
But it's very interesting
because it gives you much,
much more control over
your caching.
So yes, I think it's
a very good idea.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Did you want to
give any words about shared
workers and whatnot?
MALTE UBL: Yes.
Oh, yeah.
I wanted to use shared
workers for this.
See, we have this thing
in the background--
it only exists in Chrome.
It can be accessed
by every domain.
Every single iframe,
every single tab.
And basically, it would
provide [? Java ?]
[? for ?]
[? you. ?]
It would ask it for it.
So we'd never have HTTP
requests, basically.
And you would have guaranteed
in-memory caching.
So that's my favorite--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And most
importantly, in-memory caching
tied to one ID rather than
however many sites that you
happen to be on exploding
the cache size.
MALTE UBL: But Chrome only.
AUDIENCE: That's called
shared worker?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Shared worker.
It's like a Web Worker, only
that when you instantiate it
and there's already one
on the same URL, you
get the same one.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Very cool.
And one other question,
I was curious--
we're also looking at
using data URIs.
And I'm curious-- have you guys
experimented with that
much, and are there
disadvantages to that as well?
MALTE UBL: no, we haven't yet.
We think about it for delivering
the image with the
CSS, and we're currently not.
One thing we actually do-- we're
kind of cheating, and we
haven't mentioned this today--
but the Bootstrap makes a
request to the image
file, which is
never drawn to anything.
So it's guaranteed to be
in cache by the time
the widget is drawn.
And I think that's probably
even a better idea than to
inline it, because that's
a lot of traffic.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And obviously,
that interrelates with
inlining CSS, in that if we
basically explode the inline
sprite into a bunch of data URIs
in the CSS file, then it
becomes inline.
Then that tradeoff becomes less
tilted in favor because
the CSS is larger
at that point.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
MALTE UBL: All right, thanks.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]